okay I want to start today with a fact
check along similar lines to others that
we've done in the past of we have been
talking a lot about democratic socialism
versus social democracy and in today's
interview we're actually going to have a
conversation about when we say that we
have a capitalist system what version of
a capitalist system do we actually have
it's not just unfettered total
free-market capitalism and that's going
to be more of a philosophical discussion
but in practice one of the confusions
that has been prevalent among political
pundits and people who talk about
economics is that Denmark and Norway and
Finland and Sweden are not socialist
economies they are mixed economies they
are a well-regulated form of capitalism
that has decided to prioritize social
welfare programs in terms of funding via
taxation in contrast to other countries
like the United States which have not
made those social welfare programs the
same type of priority and there's a
graphic that's been spreading virally
about Norway which number one calls
Norway Democratic Socialist that's one
issue
and number two makes a bunch of specific
statistical claims comparing and
contrasting Norway to the United States
sort of making the case that Norway is a
quote socialist paradise of some kind so
let's look at the graphic and the
comparison and if you're just listening
I'll tell you a bunch of what's on it
and the graphic claims that in Norway's
democratic socialist system there's a
lower poverty rate and a higher life
expectancy than in the United States
that infant mortality is lower and
there's a lower murder rate and there's
less incarceration and a higher GDP per
capita and workers are more protected by
unions the country is happier they have
free health care and free higher
education higher homeownership rate the
minimum wage is a living wage rather
than a poverty wage more vacation more
parental leave and all with only the
slightest increase in tax rate 38.5%
average personal tax rate in Norway
is a 37 percent average personal tax
rate in the United States now if you
have a sense of any of these particular
metrics you might see that graphic and
realize that some of those don't really
sound quite right the idea of an average
tax rate what are we talking about the
median are we talking about an effective
tax rate or a marginal tax rate there's
a lot of stuff in there that doesn't
make immediate sense so when we see a
viral image like this making an argument
that Norway is socialist and is better
off than the United States in always the
first thing you need to do is figure out
whether the numbers it presents are
correct then you need to answer the
question about whether Norway is
actually socialist and only once you do
that can you really make a sort of
qualitative analysis to evaluate the
claim that socialist Norway is better
off than unfettered capitalist United
States so let's look first at some of
the numbers that the the image claims it
says for example that Norway's poverty
rate is 10% and the US poverty rate is
29% I'm not finding that information the
information I found based on the Census
Bureau is that the poverty rate in the
United States just a year and a half ago
was twelve point three percent and that
Norway's poverty rate was four point
three percent so that's sort of a
question mark
the life expectancy numbers cited 81
years in Norway and 79 years in the u.s.
appear to be correct infant mortality is
lower in Norway than in the United
States but I'm finding different numbers
the murder rate is lower in Norway than
in the United States with slightly
different numbers than the ones that are
presented a problematic one in my view
is that average personal tax rate number
at the bottom of the graph the effective
tax rate that people pay is not 37
percent in the United States it heavily
is influenced of course by where you
live and the cost of living of your
state and how that impacts deductions
but generally speaking most of these
indicators are correct in suggesting
that Norway appears to be better off so
once we kind of clarify some of those
numbers we have to get to some of the
more subjective claims that the graphic
makes like for example the graphic
claims that higher education and health
care are quote free in Norway I actually
think that that's sort of a problematic
way to say it they are paid for through
taxation and I think that when we say
it's free
it opens criticism of a very specific
kind which is nothing's actually free
and it starts conversations about
handouts and so on and so forth it would
be better to say countries have taxes
the United States has taxes and Norway
has taxes Norway has different
priorities in terms of how those taxes
are spent and one of those priorities in
Norway is providing health care through
taxes another priority in Norway is
providing public higher education
through taxation I think we're better
off saying that than that they are quote
free because that's both confusing not
completely accurate and also opens up a
number of lines of criticism but then we
get to the most important question is
Norway socialist and the answer is no
Norway is a social democracy in the
Scandinavian capitalism line of thinking
of organizing an economy there's a
common talking point from the right that
if indeed Norway was socialist then it
wouldn't be nearly as well off and in
order to sort of accurately deal with
that talking point from the right the
left shouldn't be incorrectly calling
Norway a socialist country because it's
just not okay and that's a really
important problem with the graphic which
is number one the United States doesn't
actually have totally unfettered
capitalism we prop up industries we
subsidize industries we have almost no
competition in many interests in
industries as I will speak with Denise
Hearn about a little bit later on in the
program and just as importantly Norway
is not a
socialist country there's a common
talking point from the right when you
show them this data comparing Norway in
the United States they will say these
things work in Norway because Norway is
a homogenous white society with few
immigrants so it just works and in the
United States
it wouldn't work because of immigration
and religious a racial diversity rather
this is just wrong
ok Norway has actually the same
foreign-born population percentage as
the United States right around 12 or 13
percent for the last year in which we
have data for both countries so that
talking point is just wrong now it is
true that the United States has more
racial diversity in the way that we
measure race then does Norway but Norway
has a number of internal ethnic groups
groups of different ethnic background
that to us just seem as they as if they
are just all white people the way we
categorize and within Norway these are
actually more significant differences so
it's it's also just not true to say that
Norway is a completely homogeneous
country so the first thing we have to do
any time we see a viral image like this
start to spread is fact check the data
once you've fact check the data evaluate
the labels that are being attached is
the u.s. really totally unfettered
capitalism is Norway actually socialist
once you have accounted for that then we
can make an analysis about which system
appears to be working better for the
people that live within that country you
should be doing this sort of applying
this skeptical eye to every single one
of these memes that spreads over the
internet because some are accurate some
are not and we're only going to be able
to have productive substantive
conversations if we all have an accurate
understanding of what reality is one of
today's sponsors is privacy calm /
Pakman this is a free service that I've
actually been using myself for a while
now and I love it you just take a few
seconds to link your debit card or bank
account to privacy coms mobile app or
browser extension for Firefox and Chrome
and what that does is a
allow you to instantly create virtual
credit cards that are linked to your
bank account so that you're not actually
putting your real debit card number on
the internet and you use these virtual
credit card numbers to buy things online
and with one click of a button you have
the ability to create multiple virtual
cards delete cards freeze and unfreeze
cards you can put a limit on a card so a
company won't be able to charge you more
than you actually want them to and it
protects you from being hacked it
protects you from companies being hacked
which we've been talking about for a
while on the program and it's perfect
for signing up for free trial somewhere
if you don't want your real credit card
number to be exposed and on file and
their app and browser extension let you
autofill the virtual credit card number
into the credit card field when you're
buying things online there are a ton of
different advantages to shopping and
paying bills with a system like this
everything is totally secure and
encrypted and in some situations you can
earn 5% cash back on your purchases it's
all completely free all you have to do
is click the link under this video to
get started and for a limited time
everybody in our audience who signs up
gets $5.00 towards your first purchase
when you sign up using that link below